PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
If you are looking
to simplify the development
of complicated conversational
experiences, then you've
clicked on the right video.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Priyanka Vergadia,
and in this episode
of "Deconstructing Chat
Bots," I will share with you
how Dialogflow CX
simplifies and accelerates
the creation of enterprise-level
conversational experiences.
Let's say PUggs is a huge
e-commerce company that sells
shoes for our furry friends.
Customer service is
critical for their business,
obviously, because furry
friends bark sometimes.
When they started three years
ago, the company was small.
Their product
options were limited,
and their customer
service did not
require too many
complicated twists
and turns in the conversation.
And the one developer
and Dialogflow essentials
was enough to handle
the demand of a fairly
simple conversational flow.
But this year, their business
has grown exponentially,
with more products,
customers, and a bigger
team, which has led to an
evolution of their customer
service.
Their customers now have
complex conversations,
which drove them
towards a platform that
can simplify the
process of developing
a conversational experience.
That's where
Dialogflow CX comes in.
Dialogflow CX makes it easy
for not just the developers
but also the conversational
designers and contact center
managers to build the
conversational flows.
PUggs team is excited
because with Dialogflow CX,
they have the visual
flow vendor, which
makes it easy to understand,
navigate, and edit
complex flows.
It is optimized for large
enterprise use cases,
allowing multiple
different flows
within a single virtual agent.
Think of flows as
a reuseable way
to contain and control
a specific part
of the conversation, such as
user authentication or payment
processing.
If you're familiar with
mega agents and subagent
concept in Diaglogflow
essentials,
flows serve a very
similar purpose.
They can be reused
anywhere in the agent.
So if PUggs has different teams
managing orders and returns,
they can effectively
work together
by calling each other's
flows while having
full control of their own flow.
They even have versioning
and environment capabilities
at the flow level, which
facilitates each team
to work on their flows
at their own pace.
The state-based data
model in Dialogflow CX
allows them to easily
reuse intents, entities,
and webhooks.
They can also intuitively
define transitions and handle
deviations from the main topic.
With the native
IVR settings, they
can easily convert
an agent into an IVR
and integrate with their
telephony partners.
And access to an advanced
analytics dashboard
provides easy assessment
of the model performance
to better serve their users.
Now that we have a
basic understanding,
let's take a little tour of
the Dialogflow CS console.
Once we are in, we see
the project and the agent
that we are working with.
We can also have multiple
agents within one project.
The graph in the center
shows a visual representation
of the selected
conversational flow,
similar to a
state-machine diagram.
Using this Graph
Setting button, we
can zoom in and out
of the flow and change
orientation as needed.
I have this very simple
agent that has one flow.
We see all the transitions here.
Then I have this
other agent that
has multiple flows branching
out from the default start flow.
If I select one of these flows,
I see the graph for that flow.
The first node of the
graph, called Start,
is the Start page of the flow.
And these connecting lines
from one node to another
represent possible transitions.
Each node of the graph
represents a page.
We can click a node to
expand it and edit the data.
Some content-specific
panels open
on the right side of the
console to give more room
to fill the details.
The Build tab on the far left
contains the sections to manage
the flows and the pages.
When you select
a flow, the pages
contained within that flow are
listed in the Pages section.
The Manage tab contains
resources and tools
available to the
agent, such as intents,
entity types, webhooks,
deployment options, and more.
We will look at all
of this in detail
in the upcoming episodes.
This indicator shows the status
of the tasks like training.
The Agent Settings button
opens the Agent Settings panel
where we can modify the agent
name, machine learning, IVR
settings, languages we want to
support, and more such things.
And on the far right
we have the simulator,
which helps us test our
agent as we are designing it.
Notice that here we can
choose the environment we want
to test in, and it even
selects the specific flow we
are testing, especially
useful for PUggs
where different teams
manage each flow.
All right, so that was
a quick introduction
of Dialogflow CX with a
little tour of the console.
We saw how it helps
simplify the development
of complicated
conversational experiences.
Join me in the
next episode where
we will follow PUggs' journey to
dive deeper into the Dialogflow
CX console and to understand
the main components-- the flows,
the pages, and transitions.
Until then, comment
below to share with me
your Conversational AI use case.
[MUSIC PLAYING]